it's nearly time to collect the Harvest
in Afghanistan's Hillman Province where
poppy fields are considered both
beautiful and dangerous
the crop is widely used to make heroin
Farmers like gulce selling it is the
only way to make ends meet
farming wheat doesn't earn us enough
money it's not as profitable as poppy
economically we've been badly hit and
that's why we've no other option but to
plant poppies
Afghanistan is the world's top opium
producer it accounts for about 10
percent of its economy a kilo of wheat
is sold for about 50 cents whereas a
kilo of opium poppies can go for more
than a hundred dollars
if there was an alternative way to feed
our families we wouldn't have to
cultivate this crop but if we don't find
another way we would defend this with
guns and our lives otherwise we have to
flee to Pakistan Iran or even Tajikistan
for work and even that's not possible
because they will send us back
the Taliban has long been accused of
taxing drug traffickers some estimates
predict the group made 20 million
dollars in 2020 from the illicit trade
after taking control of the country last
year it pledged to crack down on poppy
Farmers but now it says they will be
left alone at least for now
we won't take any action against the
farmers until we find them proper
Alternatives they already have so many
problems and we don't want to create
more so we're working to find an
appropriate solution with the help of
the International Community
Afghanistan's economy is on the verge of
collapse sanctions and the taliban's
lack of international recognition are
making an already dire humanitarian
crisis worse
we plant and cultivate poppy because we
don't have any other option those who
have Farms plant poppy in their farms
and the ones who don't work for
landowners
the illicit trade is intertwined with
Afghanistan's economy now it continues
to grow despite attempts of resistance
at home and abroad
Al Jazeera